[Applaudissements]
je sais
à la vie
publique
le pay and see
mais chez le coup le mal
le chien que le monstre ville elle nous
parle de toi millions en chef il y avait
neuf seulement à liu a terminé at-elle
j'aï
2008 un lieu
où les
watts ammann aura bien évidemment il
donne mon chien et juan carlos slim et
elle nous fuit de table aux démocrates
et à gré wael non romolo leur parcours
et cash à nana 2 en 1 semaine d'accueil
europe
nous aimons jetage annabi walla paillard
and oil à mazères nikkei c'est trop long
non mais mais là c'est un autre monde
le camp je restais pas débrouiller je ne
veux pas
aménagement nation impopulaire et ses
personnels
n'ont fait qu'exécuter leur mission
constitutionnelle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
la permanence du candidat bouteflika
très bien madame
spécialistes la presse appuyez sur le
thème pendant une demi-heure comme ça
car ce n'est
pas parce que le racisme qui
arsenal
ça
qu'on dit
wayne ou youtube
[Musique]
qu'est
ce qu'on fait
là les manifs et
little jimmy fois
où elle a le manoir à l'éthique miss
china
et que pour couvrir notre campagne
sur les cotisations fertilisants
les dons en espèces et en nature
les sympathisants et du terrain
gace et grâce à une gestion saine
je suis devenu nous avons
plus que jamais sur nous et nous sommes
prêts mais nous ne voulons pas
rentrer en effet de serre et marc et
l'accompagnement des dégâts
c'est un pur
consorts
ce geste très symbolique dire mon
attachement à la liberté d'expression
qui figure en bonne place
dans le programme que je peux poser à
l'occasion des présidentielles et je
tiens aussi à le faire ici au niveau
d'ateliers et univers très grande
liberté d'expression
bon courage beaucoup de succès
[Musique]
témoigner par votre présence ici
aujourd'hui pour votre soutien à la
presse la liberté d'expression je
constate heures que d'autres jugements
n'ont pas eu le plaisir de recevoir
l'onction
[Musique]
de m'accuser
encore 21 jours la convainc après le
nous avons fait le constat
nous avons fait le diagnostic
rapidement je vous propose des solutions
et rapidement les engagements vous
sauver l'année l'algérie
[Musique]
je me fous démocratiya tourna vers
la démocratie est une des raisons de la
mort très jeune
qui change tout démocrate ayant d'abord
société eneria aux démocrates ya
démocratie est un concept universel
c'est le peuple souverain si le peuple
qui choisit ses dirigeants c'est une
justice indépendante si la séparation
des pouvoirs
si le respect de la presse si je suis la
liberté d'expression si lentement son
pouvoir c'est un parlement responsable
et souverain
jda ouvre les bonnes prises quelques
manoeuvres bouira le dossier concernant
la cuisse de kabylie ne peut pas être
réglé dans un cadre de sous traitance et
pourquoi ils ont maintenu leurs gains
[Applaudissements]
anissa
reste que le management table de travail
non on me dit et elle a même dit
rabillard d'un
je n'ai jamais accepté la culture de la
provocation
les affaires du peuple ne peuvent être
riches et nick de la sérénité dans la
tranquillité dans le sérieux et surtout
dans un été avec l'honnêteté on ne fait
pas tricher les deux hommes la culture
ont clos la culture du coup d'état alors
que la division du peuple c'est arrivé
j'ai terminé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chaque
radio
canada je suis pas en aval en prison
pour ça donc mirta match comme cela se
fait à l'internet et de la télévision
mais je crois aussi la bouche allidina
mais télévision disait rien comme la
salamandre com
[Applaudissements]
très intelligent oh j'ai senti que
c'était mobilisation exceptionnelle
c'est passionnant et je tolère se doit
commencer par
remonter les basses eaux traitées avec
la qualité
mascate est agile
région qui se tenait
trois années maintenant j'ai prié le
langage pendant
restos du c'ur aux problèmes rapidement
parce que si j'étais élu
ça donne plus de dix siècles
moi c'est un sacré clin d'oeil à
ne remplace la télé commencé à rire
les côtes mais on dit tout
c'est pas si mal
et vous le chaoui lors de l'ès morel et
y penser
votre campagne
je ne lis pas
j'avais cru pas son truc ont battu
hébert
les grandes les basques
qu'est-ce qui est
il est riche de ses différences
c'est paulo tous la toute petite
mosaïque
vous avez à peine surtout la mairie
pacifique à leur compte et symbolique
maclean la déshydratation
à vous la tv
pleurer super content
départs précédents république candidat
il
donc il n'ya pas la paix vous n'aurez
rien n'aurait pas démocratie celle
d'investir pour sa part cheikh est dit
par exception
c'est bon
je voulais donner
dimdim et de tests comme seydou les
et dois je lève un rouge débrouille des
rues kelkoo
m
coup tu n'as pas vu de copie
pézenas j'ai reçu quelques
regrets parce qu'une décision
la caisse est question de volonté
politique
reste qu'au modèle que je fais je me
suis dit je ne suis pas de ce que les
vastes une volonté prêtée
personne
car c'est la particularité
capello 9 à un coude à coude
ce que
à voir c'était
deux choses cachées
regrette le cyclone
c'est très bien
[Musique]
parce que pour m haies
quand même et animés de bonnes
intentions qu'on à
l'envi et l'amour peut servir mono râble
mon équipe en son pays et puis je crois
que pour le français qui nie à coeur
vaillant rien d'impossible le bain c'est
le cas pour d'autres univers
je suis un vieux combattant de la guerre
de libération a sonné
nous avons commencé un travail
tout s'est terminé en 70 ans n'a cru
qu'ils étaient terminées en soit ce
qu'on peut
malheureusement
ce n'est pas le cas
qui se trouve qu'aujourd'hui à l'âge de
70 ans au lieu de jouer le rôle de pape
sy avec mes petits enfants revoilà
encore sur le chemin sur le champ de
bataille pour
que cette indépendance pour que ce
combat se termine et se concrétise pour
tous
c'est à dire
l'algérie sur ses rails
[Musique]
com
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la
[Applaudissements]
jambe
avait
on le sait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
obasohan même à chaque sujet de
l'interview s'étaient associés
yann guichard m
jeudi
avec citation
le slogan
ne tirez pas d'autre conclusion m
docteur un seul coup sûr
mais parce que
absolument
passer
mesure 1
deux en arrière
s'ils m'avaient pas
commencé
parce que
messi
yannick djalo
ce n'est pas tout
charette cours débutants
démographe pour une amende
elle fait mal
[Musique]
howard archer d'ihs il est vrai que
je connais de la vie
scolaire de l'aventuré se
termine vers la fin des gars à la
marmite à roselyne là-bas si j ai je
pris mon amour qui n'a rien à
perdre à dublin et je ne le ferai pas ça
mais
alors qu'on célèbre aujourd'hui on a
parlé un repas de l'école
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j c
pas vraiment
de
là bas
joe
miller
[Musique]
m
un film et un marché au bois auteur
de thé chocolat en passant de
la finlande la phalange bataller
une maladie grave
[Musique]
c'est à ce prix
c'est l'image mais reprendront
demain
l'eau
le chanteur
même de quelques tôt
ben ouais
moneo des grimaces
[Musique]
j'espère géré amis que vous devez exclu
de votre interview
après on doit comme
finalement qu'est-ce qui sait pas s'il a
donné une enveloppe
parce qu'il a reçu la sienne j'ai ramé
le terme enveloppe est bannie dans notre
vocabulaire politique
ou d'un pli quand il s'agit de
correspondance l'enveloppent c'était qui
vote qui ne l'utilisent pas le chèque
alors allez attristé par ailleurs un
autre
espoir a dit je peux battre
les 400 4 nages hier soir
à vis de fer mois lena
porte-monnaie s'est fait voler la mèche
les lentilles et où puis-je faire des
achats
ou mais se mêlent art d'achat ou le
meilleur le courrier
remémore le mot reviendra jamais au soir
d'un crédit de tamiser prix jugé matthew
van basten kim jee woon
[Musique]
nous aimions
comme
gisèle baillet la racj a
aussi incendié
ou le diabète gerbe et résidents
que la mp
se soit immiscé
des problèmes politiques et entre du
pays je le dis oui
[Musique]
c'est vrai
tarhouna
mais je peux vous dire
quand 92 nous avons ouvert une brèche
dans un simple que nous avons à refermer
avec les élections de 99
rare mais ne s'occupe que des ce2 ses
missions constitutionnelles tout le
reste
n'est que mensonge
je vous dis je répète n'est que mensonge
initial au score
avant de manège marivaudage à
pour
atteindre 15
caméramans allaster a dit mme hind
indiqué
rachid taha
gmt renner paula da ou en faisant à vous
dressez vous de 13h30 à l'heure où l'on
[Musique]
est ouvert
à la maison moi j'suis poule ou
raw des rousses yes intérieure
au boulou j slovène jani alors ma valise
à la passion est celle qui vous
voulez vous des manèges
[Musique]
même
jusqu'à créer un système brésil pas
dévoyer la boutique et et voiliers
[Musique]
château
e
[Musique]
passe
les
[Musique]
merci
de
ne pas se déplacer à kayes est obsolète
guy mettan
les doigts le
désarroi qui voudraient les bâtiments
devenus très attaché mais n'empêche que
je me
fais
de toi oublie si
quand on
voit le tour un contexte d'impasse
politique système bascule elle m'a
licencié
jusqu'à quand le système les a vu le
jour
[Musique]
six ans que roger roi swazi comparé à 2
les deux gros bras sans manquer ce n'est
pas toujours la nébuleuse indique qui
fait semblant oui je croyais et ferrer
ouais ouais de réponse à des événements
parce que la
magie des changements en terme
at-elle
[Musique]
dit
[Rires]
le président
ok
[Musique]
à
parce que
quiconque comment se fait-il que que
tous les journalistes qui suivent qui
supprime fils rendre des compte rendus
des articles qui sont positives
finalement faites votre enquête vous
allez voir que chaque journaliste à
ringotte et de sang
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
copé
là
[Musique]
dire
qu'il n'est pas facile
[Musique]
ok
une association
jeu
s'agit pourtant d'une autre joueuse est
envoyée
il ya des propositions et moderne et
dynamique
entraîneur à
les importants de fois
mais les as
lézignan masson n'a pas d'histoire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon
je sais chercheurs chers frères que vous
vibrer à l'unisson à l'idée de voir
l'algérie reprendre réellement sa place
dans le concert des nations
parce que nos partenaires nous ont
reconnus comme mp crédit bien gérée à
l'autorité légitime et un pays où le
journaliste pourra écrire sans craindre
d'être remis en prison ou voir son
journal suspendus ou le code de la
famille sera amendée pour garantir les
droits des femmes qui sont ne l'oublions
jamais nos mères nos soeurs nos épouses
et nos filles
beaucoup de maires ont souffert pour que
nous acceptions qu'ils soient attentes
et à la volonté populaire
le peuple algérien et le peuple des
femmes et des hommes libres et celui qui
me confisquer sa liberté se trompe
d'époque se trempe de liberté et de pays
où aller
[Musique]
quand
depuis la mort du président pour mediène
je me suis je suis resté volontairement
loin du champ politique il ya que le
président des cinq dernières années et
était
un auxiliaire enfin collaborateurs 10
ans du président boumédiène ce qui m'a
beaucoup chagriné c'est qu'il n'a pas du
tout retenu les méthodes de travail du
président boumédiène voilà si on est un
petit peu dans un genre de monarchie
absolutiste
avec mon papa parlementaire absolutise
comme disait louis xiv car tel est mon
bon plaisir
donner l'exemple et celles concernant
les femmes la justice par ex le conseil
de gouvernement s'est réuni sous
l'autorité la résidence du chef vous
réellement que j'étais allé voir le
président se trouvait à l'étranger ce
concept du gouvernent le monde arrête de
décision notamment ses conseils de
justice le président alan 30 étrangers
le taux longs dans les plans d'origine
l'algérie
j'y tiens ils ne seront pas au bourget
en toujours de croiser des mises j'étais
tout comme j'ai président je ne crois
pas on n'avait pas notre justice sa
sécurité ce ne sont pas les miens je
démissionne président
ces textes
rédigée et adoptée au vu de la
commission issad aussi s'acquitter de
0,3 mg j pas question et d'ailleurs je
vais l'utiliser dans le bijou du conseil
des ministres ce qu'il fait sur le champ
téléphoniquement
alors gérer l'état consulat
d'un président et chef quand il devient
pratiquement dans tous les dossiers
quand il omet à ne pas laisser les gens
de
rien c'est la machine qui te demande pas
les lâcher littoral c'est pour ça que
j'ajouterai que ce n'était pas du tout
les méthodes de travail du président
bédié
m
un membre
[Musique]
où
[Applaudissements]
patrice chagnard
si je chante kg s'est pas touché à mon
tgv
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pauvreté
[Applaudissements]
qui sont avec moi dans mes pensées
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous êtes un jeune de 20 ans de 25 ans
vous demandez l'emploi vous ne retenez
pas vous les faites le projet
professionnel vous ne pouvez pas le
faire voulait faire des cultures vous
pouvez pas le faire qu'est ce qui vous
est arrivé voulez vous marier vous
pouvez partir parce que vous n'aimez ni
emploi ni rock ni logement
celle-ci la route droite vers la mort
nous sommes producteurs de gaz et 4
milliards avec le gazon famille que
l'activité nous n'aurons pas
d'électricité
gt rien tout cela à l'expliquer au pape
lui même si comme cette raison qu'ils
ont toujours bien avec
10,2 millions des 100 km de millau et
son micro mètre carré de tête
parti
celle ci restera pour l'intérêt qu'ils
sont délaissés de la culture qui est
intéressé il ya quelque chose dont il
faut le comprendre
quoi ce que les gens ne veulent pas
devenir de la culture je me suis posé la
question
vous me dites vous avez 25 ans allez
allez allez appuyer votre chien geroudis
monsieur je n'ai pas de doutes pour
accéder à mon derrière je n'ai pas
d'électricité pouvoir y construire un
logis avoir de la lumière il n'y a pas
d'école à proximité de l'endroit où j'ai
marie beaupuy était donc si je vais là
les enfants seront payés des corps
celle de voir le guide fait tout cela
c'est l'état à moins de réfléchir comme
certains disent que c'est une formule
devenue célèbre maintenant le citoyen se
plonger ça ça n'est pas mon langage ça
n'est pas celui des gens qui ont été à
l'école ou chez qu'est-ce qu'il faut
changer
c'est un peuple qui n'est pas bien
qu'est-ce qu'il faut exporter ce peut
elle amener un autre la place au change
et précis dans ses passes
[Musique]
déjà des années pourquoi parce que je
suis un passionné de l'été accueille
également visés tous
ces passionnés oui c'est l'amour du foot
une lisible c'est ça les passionnés ils
se sentaient bon sens connaît ça le
passionne surtout le manteau le montois
impériale les pauvres gens de toulouse
tous des poèmes l'elysée râle tout cela
[Musique]
quand je vous parle de majorité
écrasante j'essaie de cauchemar
[Musique]
je vais
[Applaudissements]
ses moyens
[Musique]
oui c'est les gosses c'est des scolaires
dans le hall et j'ai senti comme cela
c'est des scolaires on a fait sentir
pour pour pour montrer que culé il a de
l'audience
jamais les gens qui me soutiennent et
qui m'ont soutenu nous sont allés dans
un meeting de notre candidat mais pour
pertuber métier s'ils veulent alléger le
droit et dans le respect des autres mais
appelait déjà à venait petit bémol
quelqu'un ces de
las vegas
à
[Musique]
chauffer pour paris
je le fais rien que ça
221 d'une salle d'arcade smart
[Musique]
abri oui oui mais c'est pas ça fait mal
aux années
oui
illizi
et
c'est là qu'est ce qui s'est passé
il ne voulait que l'on parle de la mort
déjà
[Applaudissements]
à
mettre la barre
très
haut en sommes donc allés halte-là les
mythiques fera
pas ce que je suggère dire une
coordination hommage marseillais outre m
à ses yeux c'est notre victoire c'est la
famille royale
donc je termine le quatrième volume très
important sera foule soit avant soit
après l'homme a besoin la foule avec des
plans rapprochés un kit alarme justement
puisque la commission des lois est venu
de vous avez 3 2 minutes
que vous choisissez tournant le candidat
choisi l'été mais les deux minutes qui
passent le jt qu'est-ce qu'ils font roma
est cool que vous avez vous des
meilleurs en deux minutes mais le
journaliste peut ajouter une minute et à
la télévision
indiquera minutes de la télévision et
fait soit pour attraper
un candidat soit pour rassurer les
réseaux et annie à une manipulation
éhontée vu qu'au niveau des
enregistrements radio systématiquement
nous il nous censure le passage parce
qu'il ya une déclaration comprend le
christ et secrétaire général mais qui en
soit la vérité donc il faut qu'on
réagisse par
communiqué m et parce qu'on ne peut pas
laisser passer sinon
systématiquement brésil des passages
depuis un
smartphone il faut qu'on informe que
cette commission systématiquement non
bloc et qu'en plus
il y en eu censure juste anormal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
les coaches de tout le canada
pourrait mener pour ce n'est tout noir
et la mine sombre il mais ils y ont vécu
les jambes et éthiques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pigé ni
katumbi est riche mais aussi des chiens
et chats
et arabes
si l'administration qui agitent la
traitera lité qui assure la continuité
de détail la quantité de tension tout
quoi ça devient est un partisan et des
partisans c'est un état pour certains ce
n'est pas un état pour tous
[Applaudissements]
et
il y en a déjà été fait sur la ste
pouvoir leur monte à la tête
la politique 6 - 4 bien sûr qu'elle
raconte est jeune on est déjà compris
moi j'ai rien inventé on va toujours dit
que la presse était le quatrième pouvoir
vous fêtez effet une fichiers
vous êtes le quatrième pouvant nous
inscrire en espérant
démocratiquement le pouvoir soit
bien d autres cieux palais où elle
milite en saisonnier aussi de les
écarter par la voie des urnes ce le plus
pacifiquement possible plus légalement
bossi cependant notre conscience avant
dans votre cour
oui laquelle est lourd
mais
rien n'est parfait tu oublies que nous
sommes un pays en phase de transition
d'un de système inique un pluralisme
d'une économie dirigée à une économie
libérale se fait pas comme ça facilement
la france n 2 sur plus de deux siècles
de tradition et a de temps en temps
encore débat
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ma démocratie
et puis c'est comme ça vous avez les
plus grandes fermes sociale parce que
les gens ont une culture du rejet de
l'étape parce que pour eux cet état qui
fait ces pratiques là c'est n est un
voleur de voix c'est un état qui
détourne me voie
puisqu'il vous êtes amis de contrôler
vous même les urnes en restant
devant les centres de vote et bien ne
quittez pas ces endroits
assister et voyez ici vous trouvez qui
est la fin de fraudeurs mais dites nous
l'acceptons parfois de la frappe nous
combattons pas qu'il y ait des scooters
un scrutin sans emploi que des peuples
on vit dans cette église et il aurait
bien le connaître c'est le droit du
peuple ne pas que c'est sur cette
pratique électorale
parce que c'était le cas
[Musique]
je radio pénis mais ces records
nous ont fait confiance et c'est réussi
pour bull est confiant
ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc la loi où son prix mais les droits
des citoyens oui parce qu'ils aient le
droit de citoyenneté c'est la raison
pour laquelle je voulais en visite
aujourd'hui je vous dis je m'engage à
faire de la citoyenneté des concitoyens
l'un des principaux axes et la
production de vos personnages et lis et
je m'explique
akalé liberia jeudi elle mejia et bien
je vous recommandais jusqu'à mon dernier
souffle de veiller seul alger si vous
voulez me liquider les kinés mois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce qu'ils disent ou quasiment plein
conditions électorales qui les
magistrats de leur rendre compte
et n'hésite pas pour rien définitif
avant de rédiger le pays
de ma condition
la
tribune pendant neuf ans j'ai compris
que vous avez fait profil bas
je pense qu'il va du cs mentale est un
tout
[Musique]
comme un
communiqué en préparation
agissons présidence et quel est votre
état d'esprit j'ai toujours été
optimiste quand on fait de la politique
on doit être de mise si l'on est
histoire je me bats pour gagner
les élections
qui se préparent pour vu la france
s'installe être plus déshérités mois le
président candidat
veut passer par la froide
ou appliquer la politique de la terre
brûlée pour l'algérie l'algérie ne pas
être l'otage du président-candidat le
peuple algérien doit prendre son destin
entre ses mains
c'est mario gomez de sunrise en marche
arrière
en attaque et le mobile me oil 9,6 voilà
un
livre de yamo atone et fiabiliser et
mellila dépendra magie
alors proposé des choses mais il m'a
fallu tout sourire
madame nous à la toussaint
chevallier il est attendu que le recours
à l'argent
parallèlement chaque
soir déjà les mauvaises langues prime
16e étape au pays el taller de l'acta
août à des cracks america il est même le
même cadre la carte mensuelle à ça va
dans une manade romain hamouma racing
team a laissé aux communes et me dire la
mamaya un âne il en coûtera litres à la
marque tout document le marque 3-1 trade
danois bateau ou un lausannois idem à
l'hôpital ou à la maladie et je need is
terrorisme
uccello tapis mao roman la finale la
polonaise wola de weeds ou d'un cap
thomas est la matrice piraterie hier au
matin qu'il vienne à miliana
abritera la
demande ouvre à lunel celui ci
comprendra une âme immortelle et micmacs
de l hymen
local one aucun besoin d'un titre selon
m
[Musique]
la poste a mis 12 litres derrière à
exhiber comme la camaro d'avoir
un lien d'amour comme un
contact important de ma part
[Musique]
d'un côté rivière passage
s'affairent à l'abri congrats monnaie
vous êtes les bienvenus nous sommes en
disposition pour vous donner tous les
éclaircissements que vous voudrez pour
vous donner tous les détails les preuves
de ce que nous allons avancer sur la
france qui a commencé il ya déjà
plusieurs mois et qui va se concrétiser
le 8 avril suel mon fils que
la majorité de nos positions ne vienne
à l'unisson série 6
quant à l'efficience de ses groupes
d'observateurs qui malgré le mauvais
temps
peuvent être donc utilisé comme un alibi
un
manipulation dans l'hexagone j'ai passé
au moins une nouvelle collection
nous avons
des élections les bras de l'un des époux
se doivent avoir il y à t'il aux
multitudes de technet
avec ça
apparemment apparemment mauvaise
nouvelle
les ya quand même il ya quand même des
pressions sur des gens par exemple
commune où adil est arrivé il va trouver
déjà quelques
jours de liberté
dans les plus grandes scènes oui oui des
jumeaux c'est la question qui
mérite quelques sons de chrome
bertonèche les candidats ma partenaire
logique
d'accord
[Musique]
demandera encore demandé audience
ça va tout seul
allô
bonjour dit
ça va
ah bon
challenge à la
imagine beaucoup j'étais gentil
à bientôt
[Musique]
les parts
voilà c'est comme ça
[Musique]
et c'est vous c'est bon ça et
je
connais
ok
scolari
nous sommes
le seul contrôleur le représentant du
président candidat
compense une bande son c'est ma question
des véhicules
le point commun
c'est un peu
et
je
je vais à sa roue des nouveautés
d'oubli moi je rêve des
techniques nous ont trouvé la mort jeudi
à 17h15 en hajiti 228 faillites en
belgique sur le market bin ghaith
sourire kerry nojoud rey juan monaco où
elle mourra comme brutal rail route à
reichshoffen oui la canadian online
arrive c'est pour ça que j'ai cherché
noise
effectivement mort s'il allait m'offrir
présidente
oui
le mondial
avec la mer apparaît pourquoi en quoi ça
vous gêne
vous
verrez qu'ils savent être aux démocrates
mais un noyau b le rapport à l'île
maurice van sant palme à moussaïab
yattara man down
to manage
tout comme l'asie c'est tout
[Musique]
de
fait vous allez à moi je veux dire être
halal
m
j'ai bougé
on m'a dit non
naturelle a dit lundi qu'il n'existait
pas envie d'exister là de toute façon on
pouvait s'y attendre c'est le fief de
[Musique]
la suite à notre demande
a
été visionnée de dollars
donna anna dire voilà ils produiront au
civil à cannes avec un bullet marois
savané
il alimente
lycée m'a tapoté vision de jeudi
amorim comme on le sait cette couleur et
d'y attirer les mâles au magic a fini
mon
fils et ma catégorie trophée coup du
malade est cerise lilas face à reims
montant la cheville est incertain on a
noté richard lane pilonné vous allez
place dans les yeux qu'il honnit vous
allez la terre dont celle la veille kg
ne vous arrête l'athlétisme échappe à
vivre les uns à hugh hendry il un
maçon mais j ai dit
où nous serons encore là bas tarkett hu
et de trois
[Musique]
ça va mal
en 2009
l'administration n'a pas a suivi le
scrutin
plusieurs membres des commissions
communales de surveillance des élections
se sont vu refuser l'accès dans des
centres de vote sans raison apparente
une information le coupé
affirme
et assure que treize mille voix ont été
bourrées dans les murs
d'alger sans l'apc d'alger centre vous
n'êtes pas avoir à être valide
[Musique]
au moins ces énoncés
on commet pas vous dire si je vais
avancer la science du scrutin si ça va
être avec on va faire leurs cours
et on verra certains bureaux de vote ont
été carrément
cas raymond brûlé il s'agit notamment de
sa mise au verbe un chat donc plusieurs
localités les routes entité barricadé
depuis hier sans que cela n'inquiète
outre mesure les chargés de la sécurité
dans la commune de la sda
particulièrement des témoins ont affirmé
qu'il y avait eu encouragements de leurs
femmes pour brûler les yeux
maintenant si où il a été brillant un
bureau itinérant
l'urne a disparu elle a été retrouvée à
20 heures le soir rien ccco tentèrent
l'astuce
c'est de semer en cours de route les les
représentants des candidats et de partir
seul avec lui et plus grave encore on a
retrouvé des bulletins de série c'est à
dire de louisa hanoune et de l'hybris
jetés dans la nature
la wilaya d'un voyage toujours
nous avons toujours dit que la fraude
était commandité et que son exécution
verrait le jour le jour du scrutin sous
le couvert de certains alibi qui sont la
commission nationale de surveillance des
élections et la présence de quelques
dizaines d'observateurs pour s'enfuir
durant trente ans bien
aucune réponse de la commission aussi
bien pour
pour les multiples recours que nous
avons présenté pendant la campagne
électorale
et ils étaient nombreux
qu'eux aujourd'hui même nous avons
envoyé plusieurs plusieurs recours à
cette commission qui n'a pas réagi
les trois candidates les façons je vous
rappelle je vous rappelle la tentative
du ministre la justice qui n'a capté que
grâce à la contribution qu'après ce que
je tiens à remercier et à féliciter
et le retrait de la circulaire
était un aveu du ministre la justice
c'est lui qui allait donc apposé le
sceau de la légalité sur une fraude
nationale nous nous pouvons réagir en
usant des voies de droit et des citoyens
tirant les conséquences
[Musique]
contre
roy
[Musique]
je pense
jean
je suis un ancien ministre et rial voilà
ce qu'on mérite la place comme à faire
chez l'ancien ministre ancien manche
espagnole il m'a frappée et m'ont poussé
à prendre le départ de la colonie on
entre
enfin j'ai tout à fait
preuve généralise bros on a tout un
véritable échange commence pas mal
madame aslaoui pacifique
on a frappé j'ai été la première à être
frappé par le blue type
incroyable
avec les congés xiam entendu
la délégation de l'eau et soeurs a
observées essentiellement la procédure
de vote qui s'est déroulé dans cette
journée et la journée précédente
statistiquement pour nous nous avons vu
125 bureaux
au hasard la procédure était un niveau
de standards que nous considérons comme
parfait au niveau européen ici il y as
amélioration et non pas détérioration de
cette
fonction démocrate l'assemblée
parlementaire a publié et les experts en
matière de femmes sont à la disposition
du gouvernement algérien pour continuer
une série de discussions bilatérales sur
la façon dont on pourrait préciser
certains points pour que la loi par
exemple soit encore plus précise au
moment de la publication des résultats
de façon à ce que quand on le maire
l'ensemble des résultats il ne puisse
pas être l'objet de critiques dans la
façon dont présent l'a sans doute des
résultats 2010 la russie bouts de jambes
et la tête
il souhaite répéter que nous ne faisons
pas de commentaire en aucun cas sur les
résultats jamais mais nous faisons un
commentaire sur la procédure et ce
commentaire est positif
[Musique]
quand le shérif à l'île jésus ou à
certains moteurs quand le film aurait
même selon mme sabah
de feu faire pire la fille chérie où
elle écoule morte-née le jeu et
vous ne triche mois calmes et el
cid abdelaziz bouteflika klout manil
face à robin fémy à
[Applaudissements]
monsieur abdelaziz bouteflika
a martelé la famille djib le baril
sid ali benflis se bat face à
rennes caen s'est dit que le malade au
sourire
j'aime douleur
ouais minul bidea
de cartes comme un homme utilise le
poulpe par achille que nos moujahidines
fille qu un mail mais que tu oublieras
walker delhi inde où il a un amour à
aider les jeunes à bin ouais donc dire
les adorons fille marketing et tera watt
est éleveuse à
katmandou dabilgou berkshire fait elle
mérite elle faire hualien dushku
yakitori alpha taureau il elle mais je
risque 12 story ouais lequel himalaya
[Musique]
lepage devient assisté hier à une
parodie d'élection le candidat blagis
modifiera a encore une fois montré toute
l'étendue du mépris qu'ils portent au
peuple algérien en confisquant savoie
dans ces conditions
je considère les résultats de la
présente élection
comme frappés de nullité en ce qui me
concerne
je continuerai à mener le combat
pour la démocratie avec force et
engagement
convaincu que je suis que l'idéal
démocratique
ne peut que tu es lyon fait par la
volonté et la force du papier noir à nos
valeureux m'attire
vive l'algerie de la démocratie et du
progrès son corps est d'accord
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonne question bonne question c'est pour
ne pas laisser le terrain du candidat
président et s'il faut démontrer au
peuple algérien de quoi il est capable
et l'a montré de quoi il était capable
le de 80% pour le prix d'un candidat
c'est une honte et un scandale c'est un
hold up électoral c'est un prolongement
maintenant électorale digne des
dictatures les plus aguerris
que l'armée a vraiment assuré sa lettre
à lire je veux que l'armée a été notre
présidente a utilisé cette autorité dans
l'année pour paralyser l'administration
est du magazine injustice et manipuler
tous les grands services publics à son
profit qui sait même pas gêné de taper
dans la caisse de l'état c'est le mot
qu'il ait choisi extrait en détournant
l'argent public pour sa campagne en
finale ce qui le poids pour moi et pour
cela tous les jours son propre
raisonnement je le jette on sait que je
ne saurais expliquer au peuple indien et
qui plante ses responsabilités pour
mettre fin au régime de la voix de
cotonou d'élections dr
seydou de bokassa et de puimisson grève
[Musique]